y
en el aniversario de la toma del
capitolio del presidente de eeuu joe
biden acusó a su predecesor donald trump
de haber intentado impedir un traspaso
pacífico del poder trump respondió que
bailén estaba intentando dividir más al
país mientras que los legisladores
recordaron lo que pasó en el ataque
rusia y sus aliados de la organización
del tratado de seguridad colectiva
iniciaron el despliegue de tropas en
kazajistán para controlar los disturbios
por el aumento del precio del
combustible la casa blanca pide que no
haya violencia y dice que el mundo
vigilará a las tropas rusas
en el mundo hay un tsunami de contagios
de kobe 19 esta frase la usó la
organización mundial de la salud al
confirmar que en la última semana se
reportaron 95 millones de casos la cifra
más alta en la pandemia aunque la
variante omicron ha dejado menos muertes
menos hospitalizados que otros linajes
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un gusto
saludarlos iniciamos en eeuu hoy hace
exactamente un año los seguidores de
donald trump se tomaron el capitolio en
la conmemoración del ataque del
presidente joe biden acusó a su
predecesor y a sus partidarios de
ponerle una daga en el cuello a la
democracia estadounidense sin mencionar
el nombre de donald trump el jefe de
estado aseguró que el ex presidente creó
una red de mentiras sobre las elecciones
del 2020 para entorpecer los procesos
constitucionales del país trump
respondió a través de un comunicado y
afirmó que biden estaba intentando
dividir a eeuu porque su gobierno está
fallando esto fue lo que dije
por primera vez en la historia un
presidente que perdió la elección trató
de evitar la transición pacífica del
poder al tiempo que un movimiento
violento alcanzado al capitolio pero
fracasaron fracasaron y nos aseguraremos
que ese ataque nunca nunca pase en ee.uu
uso mi nombre hoy para tratar de dividir
aún más a eeuu este teatro político es
solo una distracción por el hecho de que
biden ha fallado totalmente solo mire
los números hablan por sí solos no son
justificables por lo que los medios
cómplices simplemente lo llaman gran
mentira cuando en realidad la gran
mentira fue la elección misma el
propósito de esa noticia en eeuu avanzan
dos investigaciones sobre la toma del
capitolio ocurrido el 6 de enero del
2021 de un lado las precisas políticas
en la cámara de representantes y por
otro están las indagaciones penales del
departamento de justicia ambos son
procesos que entran en un momento clave
con las elecciones legislativas en el
horizonte y con muestras de que una
mayoría de los votantes republicanos
cree que el ex presidente de donald
trump perdió la reelección de manera
fraudulenta nos informa juan pupiales
hubo un fallo de seguridad había una
predisposición quien lo financió son
algunas de las preguntas sobre las que
ha estado trabajando un comité de la
cámara de representantes
los integrantes siete demócratas y dos
republicanos dos legisladores
conservadores que no fueron nombrados
con el respaldo de su partido han
entrevistado a más de 300 testigos y
recolectado decenas de miles de
documentos son audiencias que hasta
ahora han transcurrido a puerta cerrada
y que ahora entran en una fase pública
el objetivo completar las
investigaciones antes de las elecciones
legislativas de noviembre en las que los
demócratas podrían perder el control de
esa sala según las encuestas en este
periodo la cámara ha buscado esclarecer
qué hacía el ex presidente down trump en
el momento del asalto en la previa el
magnate animó a una multitud a ir al
capitolio cuando estaba prevista la
certificación de la victoria de joe
biden fue si nadie hubiera previsto
jamás una insurrección incitada por el
presidente de los eeuu hace un año un
asalto contra el capitolio este icono de
la democracia en el mundo
recientemente el comité sufrió un revés
en esas pesquisas sobre el antiguo
mandatario
magnus su antiguo jefe de gabinete
rechazó seguir cooperando
de otra parte del departamento de
justicia ha presentado cargos contra 725
de las personas que irrumpieron en el
congreso entre ellas jacob chance lee el
conocido como chamán del reino uno de
los rostros de esa jornada y quien
permanece detenido
en el departamento de justicia permanece
comprometido con que todos los
responsables del 6 de enero en cualquier
nivel paguen bajo la ley account and go
para la justicia hay un gran desafío
mostrar a la opinión pública la
veracidad de sus pesquisas y más en un
año electoral en noviembre se renovará
la totalidad de la cámara de
representantes y un tercio del senado
según una encuesta de la agencia reuters
del 55% de los votantes republicanos
cree la tesis falsa del ex presidente
down trump en la que asegura que perdió
la reelección de manera fraudulenta ante
bailén
rusia y la alianza de las naciones ex
soviéticas iniciaron el despliegue de
tropas en kazajistán para intentar
controlar las protestas en contra del
aumento de los precios del gas licuado
que los ciudadanos usan como combustible
decenas de manifestantes han muerto a
manos de la policía y el ejército
mientras que las autoridades hablan de
18 uniformados fallecidos al menos 2.200
ciudadanos han sido detenidos la
comisión europea condenó esta violencia
mientras que la casa blanca pidió una
solución pacífica a las protestas y
afirmó que el mundo observa si las
tropas rusas violan o no los derechos
humanos del mundo por supuesto estará
atento a cualquier violación de los
derechos humanos y acciones que pueda
dar lugar a la toma de las instituciones
kazajas hacemos un llamado a las fuerzas
colectivas de mantenimiento de la paz de
la otc y a las fuerzas del orden para
que cumplan las obligaciones
internacionales de derechos humanos a
fin de apoyar una resolución pacífica
y afirmó que hay un tsunami de contagios
de kobe 19 en todo el mundo el director
del organismo de drusa da nombre jesús
informó que la última semana se
registraron 95 millones de casos la
cifra más alta reportada en toda la
pandemia y esto representó un aumento de
un 71 por ciento respecto a la semana
anterior sin embargo las muertes están
bajando y la ub se advierte que la
variante omicron tiene un riesgo más
bajo de hospitalización pero instó a no
bajar la guardia
civiles si bien omicron parece ser menos
severa en comparación con delta
especialmente en los vacunados
mientras no también significa que debe
categorizarse como leve as mind
al igual que las variantes anteriores
omicron estado hospitalizado y matando a
las personas antes que el increíble
en fan de tsunami de hecho el tsunami de
casos es tan grande y rápido que está
formando los sistemas de salud de todo
el mundo over huelin health systems
around the world en más noticias del
cómic 19 bolivia dio marcha atrás a la
exigencia del carnet de vacunación el
gobierno reverso la medida porque los
sindicatos y las juntas vecinales
anunciaron protestas en contra de la
regulación porque dijeron que nunca
fueron consultados desde el primero de
enero el certificado de vacunación era
necesario para poder entrar a las
oficinas y a los centros comerciales de
bolivia ahora esta limitación está en
pausa hasta el 26 de enero el ministro
de salud jayson ausa afirmó que era para
favorecer la vacunación y optimizar la
atención
y en chile comenzarán a aplicar la
cuarta dosis contra el cob y 19 a partir
del próximo lunes la vacunación empezará
para las personas inmunodeprimidas y
desde el 7 de febrero será para todos
los mayores de 55 años esta medida llega
en medio de un repunte de contagios pues
este jueves se le confirmó más de 3100
casos positivos la cifra más alta desde
principios de julio aunque la presión
hospitalaria sigue siendo muy baja el
presidente sebastián piñera anunció la
medida de la cuarta dosis experiencia
nos ha mostrado que la eficacia de las
vacunas y también de los refuerzos
disminuye con el tiempo y también con la
aparición de nuevas variantes y por
estas razones
queremos anunciar hoy día que a partir
del próximo lunes 10 de enero vamos a
iniciar un nuevo proceso de vacunación
masivo con una cuarta dosis o una
segunda dosis de refuerzo en otras
noticias del continente europeo franz ya
multó a google y a facebook por los
procedimientos para rechazar las cookies
en su página web la senil que es el
organismo francés encargado de
supervisar actividad digital obligó a
google a pagar 170 millones de dólares y
facebook deberá responder con 75
millones y es que el organismo consideró
que las compañías de tecnología se
benefician por el dinero publicitario
que reciben de manera indirecta gracias
a las cookies todos sin que los
internautas puedan rechazarlas de una
manera tan sencilla como las aceptan
en alemania aunque la inflación se
desaceleró en diciembre se situó en el
punto más alto en casi 30 años y es que
la tasa de inflación nacional subió al
31 % cuando el objetivo del banco
central europeo era que se mantuviera en
un 2% las autoridades estiman que esta
es una consecuencia del incremento de
los precios de la energía y si esto está
pasando en la mayor economía de la unión
europea se espera que en todo la unión
europea también se registren récords los
datos del bloque de los 27 se publicarán
mañana viernes
y hasta aquí las noticias pero ustedes
sigan conectados a la señal de france 24
[Música]